really already stole my watch yeah all
right yeah yeah this is gonna go my
comment to support because that's yeah
we'll try to have anything have been
sucks he's got video right there really
periscope it might be choppy yeah well
it should automatically saved in my
phone is like a video wow cool it'll
it'll save oh really it'll save as a
video yeah it'll say what's been stress
out not what they're seeing well
whatever all right let's go to the
weekly poll live this week in comics
we've got I'm cheating spider Glenn
we're doing spider web Deadpool number
one justice league dark side war
Superman end the flash the unbeatable
squirrel girl came out last week why is
comiXology doing this to me back girl
was last week digital-first was DC
Comics bombshells the Archie and friends
gym class heroes you know all about that
one hey we've also got okay we're gonna
give up on comixology as organizing yet
no no no way to win you mean this week
this week yeah i'm looking at this we
are you interesting new releases we go
over to know there's a great have this
fresh car I got a better I got a better
this week in comics we've got Deadpool
Justice League James Bond number one
star wars number 11 call of duty black
ops everyone who I gotta read that one
detective ya know in comments hold on
those we call City Hall of duty cod why
why because you need to know the story
of the heroes of call of duty that's in
this is a single player but what do you
think they did before that who cares I
mean I'll dude I'll do that on coming or
on Rob explains I'm i do melancholy I'm
doing it call it an eagle call of duty
black ops comic book yeah on for he
needs so any Rob explains a place no
I'll be long how much explain cuz if a
very least like whatever I don't know
I'll figure it out III Darien well
welcome to the weekly poll panel guys um
so for the record they gave us a
two-week warning asking if we'd like to
do this so we're completely unprepared
but we do topics to do our normal
podcast today we're going to be
discussing the all new all different
marble releases we're gonna be
discussing the dark side war and the
masses of questions from all of you guys
so prep whatever questions you would
like if you are curious we're going to
be on youtube or on
ever if we ever uploaded to itunes to
soundcloud because they're so bad about
that yes we are recording it is being
live-streamed right there to periscope
hello a periscope viewers okay they
can't respond the other parts so alright
guys so why don't we kick it off cuz
I've opened up and talked way too much
huh let's explain why sales Lee I'm not
there are more people here than I really
that I've denied legitimately yeah like
my a hundred percent because they was
they gave us a two weeks notice and no
no you promoted I think Rob said he did
yes and but two weeks notice and when
you look at the program the weekly
people alive who is that we don't
promote her I mean 30 be the viewers
here who actually watched the show you
guys know we never promoted as a weekly
poll don't be like comic stories
illegally pull rod explains all that
weakly pulled probably how you heard
about it hey comic store Ian's gonna be
here what alright guys so uh since you
don't want to explain why you're ten
minutes before the opening time and put
cut it really close um there was a lot
of prep needed but yeah uh knows so yeah
we can talk about the all new all
different all exactly the same as before
mark well I oh that's why I wanted on it
I wanted to discuss the Deadpool oh cuz
i know you guys love deadfall yeah he's
so great and not overrated at all you're
like just to take the cables and leave
noche fix it nice try it didn't mean
he's like Tim I don't know what I'm
doing so no so Deadpool number one has
anybody read it other than me not yet
not yet we are doing it okay so here
we're gonna hear i'm gonna spoil it for
you guys Deadpool number one picks up
where the last Deadpool left off Wow
incursion it literally literally they
don't explain how he survived the death
but they explained that he still got the
family he's still got the wife they're
all on the side now something between
his death and now he's now become the
most popular super here on the Marvel
Universe okay he's launched to
Deadpool's heroes for hire yeah I got
Luke a show that
ten marble living up to the only all
different line where it's nothing like
what it was before accepted and remember
what are we like I'm actually really
disappointed like I'm I was really
excited at first I'm like good you know
I don't want it to change I was enjoying
some of these stories and then I got to
them and I'm like you know what you
could have thrown it all the way they do
what they're making Macy making you go
as Secret Wars was completely useless
yeah which is like but dead will prove
that he didn't murder because as
literally so Deadpool's now no spotless
super here in the universe right yeah so
of course he's getting hit by cameras
and he's got this whole heroes a higher
than going on yeah and they interview
him and they're like so how was your
family and he's like well we don't talk
about my family I'm estranged right like
well how's your wife we don't talk about
my wife on my strange like wow so we're
just like they're all there it's a
little bit like the x-men sec like
status where it's like Cyclops did
something and boy howdy when you find
out what it is but trust me even it'll
be so bad even though x x 600 ended on a
really really positive note where psy
class United all mutants he did
something that he must like flash them
thank you all for coming to my x-men
meeting where we all get together
together now check out my junk Yang's
I'm where the Lincoln Memorial moon what
he did we'll do that that's what drove
me nuts is like like the uncanny uncanny
Avengers what they're talking about that
yeah judgment title there like so like
there was a war between the x-men and
the Inhumans at some point along the
lawn like they hate each others like me
what happened well don't worry about
that there's each other there's no they
hate each other and the pterygium mists
make them scare oh yeah so you can't so
no more mutants again what did it
wouldn't know progression original idea
how ironic is like how ironic that with
the marvel cinematic universe is unable
to make movies about the x-men that the
that's been our vanishing yes but not
only yet that we can't make any new ones
and they're leaving the earth forever
yeah except for oh but who cares well no
no there but not only that but beast is
like switchy sides well he uh oh I'm an
accident but I love you in humans that's
been pieces just like East is a turncoat
uses on the try you know what I think it
is I think geez is a super Game of
Thrones fan so he's like javi and humid
you guys have kingdoms and stuff yeah
he's like whole finger like he does
allied yeah well he was who's on top
he's the kind of guy who like when
they're fighting toad or something he
goes man we have when I was on The
Avengers we never deal with this
and the jump on board with the x-men man
like yeah oh the expert or doing like
the Avengers chocolate x-men exact guys
yes oh it's 94 and Jim Lee's drawn us
sweet x-men okay I need I need an answer
cuz the person who sent me has been
trying to get to the panel and you know
something yeah is this a convention
center or the dunkin donuts center cuz i
don't know a vision intervention okay
the donuts center is the other floor
donut yeah it's the main kaun that's
what I thought okay see when I lived in
here in Rhode Island like I didn't know
what any of that stuff but no like you
go to the mall and that was it cuz
nothing comes here they all go to boss
me we're like man this is a small con
like how did they get such big names at
this honey little convention you know
it's funny what we're walking with Robin
are walking her artist alley and I think
we did the when we showed up they were
score like so for those you guys were
listening at home or watching a
periscope I guess now we're gonna
discuss how we arrived it around a comic
con so not only did they give us no
heads up as to what's going on like they
literally like in two weeks revving and
convention do you guys want to do your
podcast live like yeah we'll do the
podcast live sure not only that but they
gave us no directions as to how to get
in or to get our panelist badges which
apparently is this the man thing yeah
but I what I went ahead is it registered
us as press because I brought over cons
as well just in case well yeah so we
show up here and no one in the building
knows where we go to get get in like
that we're like we're panel is we have a
panel in an hour we're trying to get in
yeah and they're like okay we don't know
where you go so the website has all has
more information in the people and the
email said nothing so they walk us all
around to like this backdoor loading
dock area with these two people just
like it literally looks like where they
load the food in for everything jit by
the way that's this that's a singular
location if you ever manage to get like
press representatives are undergoing a
panel like the loading dock that's how
you get in that's the issue people just
sitting there yeah but they're not
paying attention no they are in were
like and we're like we're on a panel at
new and she's like rip here didn't ask
for our names didn't ask any pictures
here's your panel badge and then they
have this kid walking us through and
he's not explaining anything so he's
walking us on the loading dock to hear
right but we don't know anything right
and you know how to get out of here
Nigerian you're like was it he wasn't
work who he was really cool did I was a
cool kid yeah and it's only I think the
only reason II got we got in the panel's
batch cuz he recognized me no that was
the entire reason could there like who
yeah you're covered story not seen you
before yeah comics X what how much would
be like nine times
like the guy that I ran into the the
duty was selling stuff he was like he's
like you're Rob and I'm like yeah what's
going on he was like I know your voice
so I came a running gag into your
comic-con that I wasn't allowed to talk
yeah one end to the other because if I
spoke everyone to recognize and come
over but if I didn't talk i could get
across the field the problem yeah yeah
the best voice on the planet yeah no no
so that's us that's us trying to get
over here and getting getting lost but
basic what happened is so we're meeting
up with the guy who's holding the camera
right now um and where I'm like we're in
the con we're in aisle two hundred and
and so he's like I'm and I l200 we're
like no you're not we're an aisle two
hundred have you never been to a con do
you not know how it works I'm so that
when they're on earlier and I'm like
Rob's like where are you and I'm like
I'm in the arena under the scoreboard
I'm using what scoreboard I go look up
good it's the big thing in the middle of
the con he's in a complete different
room I'm like another building yeah come
on no there's no direction there's no
traffic there's nobody saying that we
have to section no overhears artist
alley we don't know we were in artists
alley we're walking around like wow they
got a lot of big names just as a really
small I'm gonna happen half of them
cancelled they like you sure ok so
that's the story that so let's let go
let go back to Deadpool um so the big
thing is and this is I wanted to bring
up dead pool because I know you guys
don't liked it all right like one of
denville you did I like the last one all
right i'll say they're like you didn't
like what we've now Deadpool fans I've
gone wrong i'm sure there's deadpool
fans here right their dental fans okay
if you've read the last run then you
know that that is the sound sad clown
face we had the talking to himself phase
now we're at this sad clown face yes and
no one likes the sad clown face but me
apparently plunge if you like it you
like a heel he likes a sag fine i like
the idea of it but I'd Rhett I the only
my favorite versions were like the one
where he was like hanging out with
Fantomex and being like I'm kill kids Oh
x factor the X Factor I'm like that is
cool this Deadpool is cool they're at
know a Deadpool being like I'm Harley
Quinn of the Marvel Universe herpaderp
no thing that was the mark way run yeah
the mark way well what Slade is like no
mark waid went on when i record saying
like if i had known what deadpool blows
before i said yes i would never have
done it he didn't avoid him at him he
never heard of him he was like okay i'll
write it whatever i'm mark wait like the
most popular character in the Marvel you
started but he wasn't then he's actually
made unpopular I told us he was popular
in the sense that he's an antihero like
Wolverine he was a cool costume because
he looked like spawn no he was talking
about he was no he had he had this
constant like spider-man I'm doing gasps
stroke he just looks like all the weapon
x thing too because when he popped when
life L wrote him and he popped up like
it was like oh Deadpool like yeah I'm
part of weapon x to Wolverine and fans
like oh my god maybe we'll finally learn
some yeah exactly lady through dental
will know and they're like now you won't
know well they've even been appointed
that actually now on cuz Sabretooth
actually was talking like in the new
comic this is seamless sabertooth by the
way I'm really sorry for anybody who
hasn't read Deadpool number one cuz I'm
through a Deadpool everyone but there's
a scene with saber-tooth then there were
he even like they're commenting on all
of the old stuff yeah he's like oh I
feel so I feel so I feel so good for
dead please the only one of us that
doesn't remember anything still cuz then
pulls the one that burned his family
killed his wife I did all kinds of crazy
stuff right is the only one that does
remember any of it well he's going to
then yeah that's the sign that's what
set up right there that's totally tell
you for shadow yeah exactly okay so
that's Deadpool I like it if you like to
last run a Deadpool go check out
Deadpool it is resort of reading it I I
plan on reading it for off the racks
after eat tonight are you reading
tonight yeah so as a font as a part
let's go back and forth years so they
did that one so has anyone else right
dark side war Justice League yeah it's
great you're gonna actually read each
other if you read DC the the jason fabok
Geoff Johns run of dark enough jar of
Justice League has been spectacular oh
yeah no there she was except the last
one was drawn by somebody else yeah boy
they had the drug gods yeah but there
may it was amazing but anyway yeah has
anybody read the current dark side stuff
I read the Batman issue which was
garbage I want to know they want to know
if you think that Batman is ever
get powers outside of the Mobius sure oh
no now I me like oh you mean he leaves
the mobis chair it's gonna be one II
can't leave it we'd established that
yeah well it is Batman book you can't
get off the chair he tries he bleeds
yeah okay I can't like [ __ ] should like
the Mobius chair Batman like go into
other books he already is we got his own
book oh yeah his own dark side Ward
Scott Snyder's never gonna write an
issue about that uh like that's got a
robo bet yeah rubber bat teamed up with
the Justice League oh he's got he's got
he's got Jim Gordon Robocop yeah you
know okay I was talking about comic book
guy I was like so how are like the house
the whole Batman thing working out with
Jim Gordon's like it's awful no one why
the Batman comics cuz they don't care
about Jim Gordon no look at ignis I keep
it on topic for this week right there
was a team up with Jim Gordon Batman and
the Justice League yeah how are you one
of my favorite moments so far up to that
point yeah so now that I now that you
have a right I will spoil it for she was
it I want to read that that's awesome no
actually that the ending I mean without
going too deep into it it's really cool
because the whole whole idea is that Jim
Gordon's like what did Batman do is move
like he took care of Gotham but we know
he left he moonlighted at something ya
see moonlighting ads so he teamed up at
the Justice League and they're all like
we know it's you Jim you know we haven't
talked really highly of you we know it's
you we know it's not you know our Batman
they like we got you because your
detective skills so what they did was
they brought him in like this there's
this giant corpse and Jim Gordon Batman
has to like go over the giant corpse and
like we need you to figure out what
happened because we need to know if this
is a threat right we have no forensic
psych right on the Justice no cuz you
know Barry Allen's too busy running
exactly do have one of those or a little
Batman is going to return to Detective
Comics I mean no oh yeah I know you
could do that they could legitimately
just be like detectives another East
continuity whatever so but no so what
ends up happening though is he goes
there and he uses his forensic knowledge
and its really awesome and he even
proved himself that he's an asset to the
Justice League cool and its cool the way
they do it because it's all I feel like
we need to figure this out and then he's
like so he's trying to like using the
suit to pick up like a giant rock and
he's like I should sam little help you
can't pick it up or the like we need to
search all the caves this is gonna take
weeks guys in the flash like Powell it's
over here so he shows that him working
very well with the Justice ledge
Gordon being like so when there was a
huge earthquake that destroyed the city
why weren't they hear that was like
because it's my city it's my really you
know one choker took over everything
yeah and turned everyone into zombies is
e you turn them into zombies 2 you said
it so here's what I think it's gonna
happen like with that comic stems thing
no he didn't like ninety percent of the
DC stories are gonna be like why did the
Justice League show up that's the
problem like literally every time but
like when Batman is falling from the sky
when he's fighting the urban oh uh
there's at any time like Batman's like
underwater he's drowning just say
Superman show up and they made a comp
they did okay in defense of Batman in
that situation they did make a cop
reference to that eternal when the city
is burning down there is literally
they're like how many asked us do we got
left and he's like we have we have like
three batarangs three smoke grenades and
you always have the Superman card right
and they said that he's like okay and
now that's it well can I got it I got it
that car the city is burning what's the
worst-case scenario that the city burns
to the ground alright we're losing
everything i've got no money left i have
none of my allies left I don't know
who's trying to frame me where the whole
city is burning down the police are
against me what did I call the god I I'm
gonna hold I only get one for a month
and I don't want to waste it on this
game it goes yeah I gatos gold like
video hang on to it I don't know I'm
gonna hold on to that you know any what
always block in my mind about that
situation though okay you want to hold
the Superman car Joe he's too busy right
let's call the flash card yeah coach
call the dream my dream car GL he'll do
it again if you've got seven members of
the Justice League six of which you can
call even if you use aqua manage your
last resort when the harbor's attacked
nobody's coming new vodka man is awesome
new Aquaman assessed by the way I just
had a are you reading me walk him in
he's now a god yeah like they're like
not just God as nars it he's got it a
seal so they're all like it's it's the
new gods but as Justice see I'm like I
want to do a video about Aquaman and
like do like here's how it used to be
and here's how it is now in the new
foods you it is like the reason why he's
cool the new to now is because before
that people were like he can talk to
fish
right now we murders people know what ok
I will say this about occupied now the
funniest thing i found the dcu everyone
got major changes Batman got replaced by
a robot Superman got now a t-shirt no
powers right yeah Wonder Woman now is
the god of war with a full suit of armor
so Sokka man changed his shirt he's like
orange no we're going back at least he
didn't get his hand eaten by piranhas it
replace it with a hook because they
legitimate like the decisions with
Aquaman where they're like looking up
pretty and awesome he is yeah well he
didn't grow a mullet a beard his hand
cut off his wife get murdered and then
just just brewed the whole time that's
because that's that was Aquaman they
don't forget like oh man it's this idiot
who her like he's been a tool ish emo
like jackass for forever well even now
in the DC you like I love Geoff Johns
run with Aquaman yeah but the McConnell
said of reverting him back to being sad
about everything right cuz like Oh
Mehra's got everyone against me which I
just want to save everyone and I'm gonna
put on darker colors cuz i'm emo now
back in blackest night when they brought
back i'll commit among all right right
on he's back oh wait he raises Dombey
fish yeah miss Dombey fish a duck yeah
so I mean after he came back to life I
feel that zombie fish like a clay
attacking people why sharpest wrong with
zombie fish it's dumb you know that
happening Grayson the latest issue of
Grayson he fights a Zaza in the latest
issue of racing Grayson and Elena are
attacking an island and a giant killer
whale attacks them oh and he's like well
so they fight that and then they see all
of it is like a zombie whale with like
spider legs he was like correction
zombie whale with spider legs hey cases
back into the scene he's like Free Willy
wow it's Grayson I mean what a year old
Reverend Elena yellow diamond accent
heli make some business Doubtfire jokes
well a man okay helaina was like oh
you're so bad with your pop culture yes
I've been the cave literally but the one
of theirs all right so anyway so now
we're Dark Star Wars awesome oh I will
say this though um so far dark side
where Mobius Batman is awesome yes like
trying to like how can I look is
horribly written it is but that concept
that he could be anywhere anytime and I
loved it when the cops are like you
can't arrest people before they can
where they do the crime so now his
answer is fine I'll move them to Alaska
that's that is so it's funny cuz like
Gardens like you can't do that so if you
ever read it Batman now appears to the
cops get the criminals he's like you're
going to rob the bank like but we didn't
he's like but you're holding weapons and
that's illegal and it'll pick him up me
like boom middle of Alaska yeah your
closest place to save yourself as two
hours that way you might want to bundle
up and that even warps away but like his
whole interaction with Joe Chill like I
read all that that was stupid I don't
know horrible but what I do like adult
like actually is Superman so Superman is
the god of strength right yeah and like
flash is outrunning death in his book
cuz he's the god of death it's Superman
a Batman is the god of knowledge so he's
dealing with I have so much knowledge I
could do all this stuff we're done well
honey super he's like I'm the god of
strength I'm going to a diner and I'm
going to demand pie we're just another
Superman three when he turned bad you
went to the diner he gave buddy a hard
time right well he goes to the diner and
it's funny cuz they're sitting there at
the diner and they've got um once it
goes up and Jimmy Olsen show somebody's
like Batman Superman we need your help
come help us out and he's like I want
pie 80 slaves to counter and then like
he throws Jimmy out the window and then
Jimmy said what are you doing I need
your help but he's like I came to this
diner for pie that's why I'm here and
Jimmy's like no you came because this
guy treats you like a normal person and
she always treats you right and this is
why you came here and like you see like
like the slight vision of like regulars
claro and it like wakes it's today snap
him out of it he saves the city and that
he leaves he's like uh what but I will
say this though like in supermans
defense if the pie is good enough then
you give her the gun you have a
responsibility but who is your God like
strands if I went there and they were
like you're some pecan pie like some
delicious pecan pie Superman and like
some eggnog I would be like you it's
crisp no crime is getting one today like
you know cry why why did metropolis
almost burned down to the ground
Superman was eating pie he has super
speed he could eat it in a second that's
a flash goes oh yeah but not supposed to
like hauling down here supposed to save
her that's a courier so Superman with
all of his infinite power and ability
and everything he can do huh it's just
gonna i can say i'm gonna eat my pie
killed four members that's it rent my
conversation killed four members of the
audience all right well we're not
talking about I love when they leave and
I like calling them out on so here's a
question because this is he here eight
like Chalmers what's up is for quitters
better pecan pie or apple pie apple pie
I like pies okay poke me what pumpkin in
there pumpkin pie cream there's a lot of
people who don't like it PAP goodbye no
but kanpai is amazed you look hurt it
down yeah we gotta both crap on over
here so they don't know what they're
periscope did not get one vote out of
everyone especially if it's a little
warm it's got some a vanilla ice cream
on it alright so moving out of this
calling I don't know the guys from New
York Rita now so okay so moving out of
the next discussion let's go ahead and
move to Star Wars came up this week yes
okay shattered Empire ended last week so
we actually can come talk about an older
topic yeah juice or not I really love
what they're doing with the whole like
journey to the force awakens yes it's so
cuz they're feeling everything it likely
they start with episode 1 and they say
okay no no like they have episode 1
because they have like obi-wan and
Anakin which covers between 1 and now my
way which Anakin is it this is this is
Peyton Christian yeah okay it covers the
error between like it's written by a
greg pak and it covers the era between
when obi-wan Kenobi was like yeah I
don't really know what I'm doing but
i'll take you on as a as a protégé
because what's the worse that could
happen where's they gonna happen with
anna covers it covers that time pure but
that's what they're doing like it's all
these really cool comic sure they're
fully into the hole I mean like growing
to the portal it yeah there was a good
cartoon show called the Clone Wars both
of them and it's still canon by the way
yeah it's still cannon oh no I know well
okay has anybody read the comic for a
Chewbacca no okay if you have not read
Chewbacca do you like Star Wars and you
like rock over Kooning the group
relationship to get Chewbacca cuz it's
just Chewbacca with a little girl that
he's trying to save is the exact same
thing cuz she's like oh you look like a
mercenary can you come help me and it
were like oh and she's like okay so did
you
understand me oh I'll take that as a yes
so why do you have a bow caster last
several hundred questions that he just
oh that just occurs to me we ever see
the Ewok movie caravan of courage or the
Grady walk adventure oh yes they're
great because okay there's these amazing
little terrible movies called that you
walk movies were made right after Return
of the Jedi stay always there always a
little bear costumes left over yeah and
so they put the the people in the bear
costumes and they sent them out and
there's one we're like a little girl's
family is murdered yeah and she's like
stranded on Endor I what I love it up
both those movies were so separate from
each other yeah they had nothing to do
with nothing to do each other it's like
one didn't work I start him an idea like
that movie is kind of fun cuz wilford
brimley helps her out and that's amazing
hold on Wilfred Brimley look trooper
movies the old like kindly hand her a
whirl diabetes yeah he's my god Bettis
yeah he's also from the thing but he is
also selling oatmeal huh but Wilford
Brimley's in the end in the forest but
wouldn't have been way cooler if Chewie
was her companion that I would have been
like oh and that's exactly what the
concept of a comic is so basically take
if you've seen Star Wars rebels Ezra's
kind of thing where he's like the kid
who's been cast aside his family's being
whatever that same kid basically right
but now without Jedi powers yeah with no
powers so she needs Chewie to save
everyone and it's the funniest thing in
the world series right it's like a
four-issue but i guarantee you just like
Groot and Rocket Raccoon were like a
one-off like did you like it with the
movie this is gonna be like chewies on
his own adventure seized it we're making
a movie the chewy and little girl movie
will do that that's Disney now yes there
are roads cartoon show in which they are
Legos I know it's fun yeah no I love it
so lego true it also is amazing about
that and the Daniels the original
through c-3po yeah I'll do it yeah I'm
let me do it yet periscopes got a
question okay all of hairs go who's the
better villain dark side or Brainiac
dark side I had that debate with
dominant go check it out on that channel
and I'm gonna go with react no dice
Brainiac uh yeah I know it's brainy
because brandies thinks everything out
darkside just shows up a monologue well
it depends on which beach my army is
fighting over there and I'm over here
Superman come face me honest
for me the Superman animated series both
versions are like are equal like easy to
eat on the show if you like oh no oh no
trouble okay so sense to keep this under
time and we have quoted people in here
may have questions what we'll do is
we'll put this right we're at
twelve-thirty right now well put the the
comic of the week discussion on hold
okay and makes you say everything in the
world is amazing right now because
everyone agree everyone seems to think
that I like everything and they don't
even understand that i only talk about
what i like that's the difference right
i get i don't talk about the addressing
channel like it was just like British i
herded this then you become a club yeah
you won't know like a really bad justice
wasn't it and yeah just like yes yeah so
technically never did he never did in
other words hey Joe okay so we'll just
you how to do this simple that
microphone doesn't work so if anybody's
got a question raise your hands will
shake em a periscope what do you got
well if you want us to fight out house
and we will fight like if you want to
say sounds horrible and Rob needs to be
the mob will do it it's good did you
hear about the math McConaughey dropping
out of car DS the galaxy two yeah I
didn't know it was it like her I was
only supposed to be out him I heard was
supposed to be in a Marvel movie it was
all I heard why did he get out of it uh
probably make more real movies yeah
sorry for questions one who do you think
you would have played and to do you
think it was a good decision or bad as
Adam warlock and yes yeah well I would
be sua conta here playing on Walkman the
most disappointing thing no you kidding
me damn I live here I think it would
have been amazing at all made it would
have been an amazing atom or a similar
rumor but it was that man theme Akane
was gonna play Norman Osborn which I was
totally on board there ah why do I have
a feeling it has something to do with
the Inhumans I'm gonna go with that is
something on the inhale iskcon that is
falling apart well it's falling apart
use my peeps like we don't even know if
Vin Diesel's gonna do it yeah it was
video it was gonna be black gold yeah
yeah okay yeah like Matthew McConaughey
is gonna
human out in space fighting the
guardians of the he could be in its Ione
Arctic yeah i mean the guardians are in
space all the time yeah so are the
Inhumans yeah okay if I am space you
mean the blue area of the moon yeah
that's cool but what it could mean you
don't know you know how the Marvel
movies work he could have been an
inhuman who showed up and gardens of the
galaxy a five minute cameo leading into
another movie named me an inhuman that
ended up on the far side of the universe
that wasn't trying to destroy the Kree
Empire black ball he's a gun every time
yeah I don't know I mean like I it's too
bad we lost Matthew McConaughey if it's
in fact true I would like to see Mantha
me can I just innocent min to Marvel
movie so I don't care what wheels as
long as he's not like Carol Danvers
boyfriend like I wanted to be someone
who who got like a roll like that and
like isn't it Pepper Potts wasn't it up
good it's all true she pretty much
dropped like I don't want to be the
girlfriend that's like punk you ever
give her fire powers not hair braider
higher suit make rescue like do that I
don't know why they didn't get we made
warmer she's unbelievably 1000 iron man
suits and just get in a single one
barely anyone gotten an Iron Man suit
and I ran three what a 15 I saw it I saw
a joke video and you two about that what
they're like yeah they made a joke that
like the Avengers are attacking and he's
like why doesn't every one of the
Avengers have an iron man yeah it's
inexcusable that we didn't have an
opening sequence like the age of Ultron
take her to leave it but that opening
sequence pretty cool if they were all in
custom made to iron man yeah like the
iron Legion like a little bit sore ah
just be more [ __ ] to shed especially
by the way like at least at least a
captain america you can do he can do the
shield in the city could you imagine
like an incredible hulk oh it is like
this is one heck of a tangent you gotta
so many cameras and just playing have an
awesome we went for Matthew McConaughey
to an entire Avengers Iron totally you
know what if they go into space they
will get iron man sues Garrett I'm
calling it now but it'll be weak ones
that don't have powers oh well it'll be
like ones these are my space travel yes
they'll be destroyed by the bad guys and
then they're super suits will be
underneath another like tentative oh
yeah death America it is chain mail well
the joke video basically the concept was
like like 20 sexy cool if you think you
can all handle iron man
so they all take one they're like
fastest rescue ever right yeah what he
doesn't want you know what the reason
why no one got an iron man suit any of
the Avengers movies is because Tony
Stark's want to prove that he's not as
good an iron man is everybody else good
well that an and to bring it back
because Matthew McConaughey wasn't there
to build them that was like like I
remember sasural I just wonder pond with
a hammer and as I hit him in the chest
and like well that was that was fun came
over anyone does anyone else have a
quote yes it's very funny okay I did the
three starla shows which one's your
favorite Star Wars 2 tartakovsky from
2003 Khan was the regular chrome was
from 2008 I think and then rebels rebels
for me it goes the Turk the the honestly
I think I got to go rebels just because
it's not in the Clone Wars well but that
that that Kenny tartakovsky should show
was unbelievably good look okay I do
love but some was close this was the
problem with colon wars both of them
though I think is that because it wasn't
full disney disney they didn't fully
like they part of the problem and i read
an article about this that the the
reason why clone wars plays out of order
is because lucas kept jumping in and
being like I want to do for equal
episode yeah so because of that it's so
all over the place I you have to watch
it with that episode guide 201 go to 311
come back to but yeah that's true i mean
like Lucas and because of that i love
rebels because rebels are just 1 through
13 yeah and was right and you know what
like I there were two moments I to die
one moment in the turf at ski show which
was amazing yeah where Anakin goes to
meet these like crazy tribe and he like
has the spirit journey and he sees
Vader's image and it's amazing but the
moment that made me like lose my mind
was in rebels when Vader shows up oh
yeah and it's james earl jones yeah and
he single-handedly defeats both canaan
and Ezra and then is like I'm coming
five abreast to you like yes supposed to
be scary and unbeatable and one
ended cuz he's that's what he does an
empire when like looks like we got it I
got the force invaders like bamp bamp
bamp bamp yeah I could kill you in an
instant realize it or not it's because
you're my son on that topic I want to
ask you a question let's hear it how do
you feel about how they're handling
Darth Vader in his own comic Jason
errands turned him into like a jaw
singapore i love how powerful they may
know they're hammered at home why
wouldn't he do he can't pull things out
of the sky look he's amazing that was a
prob with like that's one of things I
liked about the whole expanded universe
before disney was just like yes that's
what i liked i like the expanded
universal like i like i like Vader where
they were just like hey look like the
vader that you saw in the movies was not
like Vader rights like like that was
yeah yeah for suddenly for the same come
on star killer oh I got a blast playing
that game the whole time I'm plan that
I'm like why isn't he very good at that
killer ending though or he's like no
we're supposed to rule the galaxy not
with you oh that ends da and then they
made a clone yeah biggest one of
everybody shut up so I can talk so
though we just like the podcast what are
you trying to say Rob you're quite fun
don't you get it out man i got rings on
my yeah well that would that would be
I'm can we post yeah yeah I fell a bow
stick yeah let's hear Rob but uh window
see that that's my love my fingers is
the Vator that I love in the comics is
isn't he cool it's so amazing just like
it's like the Dragon Balls be seen yeah
and when goku's fighting freezer the
free was like i've been using one
percent of months later he's like I've
been using like a tiny fraction of my
power and just so you know like I could
just wipe all of you out right now but
I'm gonna give you a chance you know
like that's that's a later yeah look cuz
that's what he were supposed to be he
was supposed to be this like
larger-than-life super dark like unable
to conquer yep being that's how he was
presented and I think that's how the
color that's not Jason there's yeah and
that's it I always a comic cuz of though
I don't like that why wouldn't he want
well good
when they when they take over the tan
teve like why he's just going Oh force
who I just push alter illa out of the
ship through the corridor that's
basically what he did in stearns one day
three no yeah I know like they're
attacking that he's like what are you
doing I'm gonna blow everything up yeah
that's all she needed was a maniacal
laugh then no one can sir that no one
can succeed then no one there's no
attention there it was around now Luke
has to get so much stronger though yes
so that when we go to empire strikes
back it makes no sense yeah any but the
book is all right there's my battery
died oh def what for the record for the
record Rob it won't ask you about this
then real quick resurrection X F a
resurrection F do you think that in DBZ
they've gotten too powerful now with the
ability to time travel when the ability
to say like like I'm gonna turn the
clock back three seconds okay I mean
immediately finds like the freezer fight
lasted over 100 episodes and like in
terms of time was five minutes long yeah
he was alive let's get out it was a five
minute long fight that lasted over 100
episodes a lot can happen in three
seconds that's true that's like two
seasons could you imagine that like they
do everything in the end of the like
this will have been five seconds of time
I mean cuz freezin was like my thing fun
for a little while and then like he he
was when they charged up yeah like he
threw the fireball into the intern Amick
and he was like this planet's got like
five minutes and it's like okay well
that was the longest five minutes in the
history of cartoon said it was four
episodes at 20 minutes each yeah it was
and there was a problem is like the
whole time travel element is interesting
but the issue that you're gonna have now
with dragon ball z is or I guess with
dragon boss well at least they made it a
friend so they can't it's not call upon
thing yeah it's gonna be like the super
and on the speed dial thing like when do
we call the god of destruction yeah
exactly seem like you only use it once
the resurrection of F like the most
important I'm like well let's just keep
the plan from being blown up so we can
like in the movie no no they did they
did it's like any more snacks did you
not pay attention oh that's right
definitely I mean that show is all
padding it's just yes yeah I'll go out
of that
far right are you good point of the kind
of colleges we make we made a joke about
this that that no one would ever
recognize Rob without his voice dollar
guys the same people so did she has
nothing like people here earlier me
Robert talking about the people who came
in early but we were discussing that how
Rob is not because I get on camera he
gets on camera Rob doesn't sand no one's
gonna know what that is voice right it's
true so I does anyone have another
question question you know you wanted
this is one of you to take a gauge of
Ultron okay uh-huh nothing going on go
to ml heaven we stuck with it's not I
mean so Sal why don't you go first tell
us why age of all cherish your favorite
eh Ultron is my favorite movie in this
very specific circumstance you get that
awesome Iron Man Iron Man Hulk fight was
really cool yeah it really beefed up
that whole Buster was pretty it was
amazing that was amazing uh well how'd
you feel about how they handle Ultron up
it was your favorite movie he looks he
looks like no Ultron I've ever seen uh
and James Spader playing him was very
unique and interesting would you like to
Pinocchio lines those were rarely really
not forced and no i mean like James
Spader denies job that was cool I mean
like I when I was reading the interviews
they're like James Spader like people
gave him a standing ovation when he gave
his first performance and I'm like oh
great uh but no like vision looked cool
okay there's a shot where vision picks
up Scarlet Witch mmm that's a definite
it's okay that's like a cover oh yeah
that was awesome there were there were a
few moments where I'm like whoa what
Jeff wishing a comic book which i do
find weird that movies are
up for their relationship yeah but now
we have a comic about him in his robot
wife which by the way is crazy oh it's
awesome for easy dark okay so ant-man I
love ant-man and I really do actually
love a man in guardians my two favorites
yeah but a man i love it because the
Avengers movies are great but they're
building towards something that I'm kind
of losing interest in like I'm kind of
losing interest to where we're going
with this and I want the movies to be
standalone again because that's not
allowed about phase 1 everything was
standalone it was this is Captain
America and this is the winter soldier
and this is a story about Iron Man and
Iron Man fighting stuff announced with
age of Ultron everything it's like now
everything has to build towards the
infinity war and with everything
building towards the infinity war every
time I go to one of these movies now I'm
kind of like all right so where's the
build-up and where's the action movie
like where is the the connection a man
was awesome because it was stand alone
again introduces two and manhandled
ant-man in a great way we even got one
of the classic two superheroes meeting
up and they have to fight because that's
what you do in comics right even though
it makes no sense hey I'm here to stop
the end of the world oh me too you want
to talk about it no let's fight that's
what we do like if i can add on to that
really quick just the first one i was
teasing you allergic all trucks are you
jumping here oh the fact that like uh
that's how phase two three whatever
those santalum movies should be cuz at
first like phase one you're thinking
who's gonna be in it like who they're
gonna reference right like who are they
gonna make nods and callbacks to your
not expect when you're watching Captain
America you're not expecting iron man to
show up right yeah but after Avengers
it's inexcusable these not sure what it
is and that was the problem cuz in iron
man is like gobble they've got they got
the president oh we're not require man
yeah well I shields overrun by Hydra we
don't need we don't need to call
everyone know and let's let's not call
for but input the ambient story made
sense because it was ant-man on a ground
level yeah was it like a world-ending
catastrophe well they wrote they would
they wouldn't have called in the Avenger
sure that they also wrote the story
around it so that you could have the
characters that like really warranted
the story like for them to appear in and
that was awesome cuz that's what phase
for you should look like you should
watch like Iron Man 4 or whatever
they're not gonna make our FF for but
like Thor 3 that's the thing I think
their fall on the ant-man formula Thor 3
is just a buddy cop movie with Thor and
Hulk yeah which is exactly what I want
from a Hulk movie and
so yeah well it may be even said they're
gonna be gay men to based upon how well
and wait at least literally called a man
in the wasp like it's like anyway yeah I
hurt you want to jump in our ears okay
so guardians guardians we go um yeah man
Jordan to the gal she was really because
of like the awesome next wrong awesome
it's one like that's what made me oh
yeah that music oh my music really
that's the entire thing no I thought it
was a really good movie because like it
took a break away from like everything
in the Marvel Cinematic seater so far
like it was exactly a min they do have
away from it it's guys out in space
somewhere and in the whole blight at
least I hope that we have at least that
I would have anyway we'll be like at
some point along the line like they'll
be an Avengers garden galaxy console
because i want to see like Peter grilled
meats Tony Stark yeah that'd be amazing
well that's what the guardians of
gossett he showed up up there yeah and
then the coolest thing ever i just kind
of change it off of that when Tony Stark
left of the guardians of galaxies and he
called them up and he thought he was
leaving a message yeah it's like a whole
monologue about how amazing guys where
he can't wait to work with and blah blah
blah blah blah going on you know and
he's like and going through the whole
thing at the end of it like rocker bert
kouns like does he think he's leaving a
message she's alive right now county oh
oh it's not a phone but ya like like the
guards the univer gardens the galaxy is
a really cool concept because it was
literally like a standalone film it was
a chance for moment to say here's a team
that on the knoll circumstances I never
thought they would have made a movie
about now that's totally isolated like
there's no feature no nothing from any
body of the rest of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I mean at least an ant-man you
Anthony Mackie right and so it was kind
of like a high end but guardians of the
Guardians the galaxy the whole separate
thing is no there's not one word
mentioned before Hulk anybody they did
mention the gems oh yeah yeah it's
practically Marvel cosmic phase one
exactly it's like it's like Iron Man
again exactly Independence Day made it
so cool because it was so fun and it was
hilarious like and I'll be honest if you
didn't fit anybody it's one of those
things like Robert Downey jr. Attorney
story yeah you know it Robert Downey jr.
play to tony start and it just made the
character and it is one of those things
we were like I can't see anybody else
playing Tony Stark in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe you know if Robert
Downey jr. says I don't want to do Tony
Stark anymore well then it's time to
kill off 20 * it doesn't
health of these you can replace them
with like somebody else it doesn't it
doesn't help that they've since he
became so popular remodeled Tony Stark
in the car I gotta be that's a smart
idea by the way we're model you're
unkillable cartoon care there after a
very fallible human person who could die
at any minute right exactly yeah that's
that's a thing you know with guarding to
the galaxy was it Chris Pine yeah yeah
Chris Pratt Pratt mine is a sis Keys
Newkirk yeah so Chris Pratt him playing
uh playing Peter quill perfect yeah well
it wouldn't have been what I thought
like they had to model him after Chris
Pratt after that exactly but he does
such a good job man that you're
absolutely right seeing those two
together yeah like Tony Stark Balon I
will give you my entire fortune for that
mask because opening it up will give me
a whole new fortune like just seeing
them work the ah that's it it works it
works so well okay so who had the better
argument guardians oh yeah who a
horrible time you'll put it back on her
two eyes yet who argued their point back
age of Ultron did best right that'll fix
my begrudging you just was bowling he's
gave a question man yes it better be
right on they're saying that it's gonna
be red hood yes um fans great villain do
you think they'll have trouble
introducing him as he's not known to the
general audience is he and secondly we
should play red Oh who's your place as
far as Red Hood i think i'd probably the
most expert on red hood at this point in
a third group yes but red hood is weird
because red hood was like a underground
Batman fans knew him but if you weren't
a bat me if they didn't know who it was
and recently over the last like five
years yeah he's been shoved to the front
like oh yeah he's more he's getting
almost as prominent his dick grayson
people talk more of a red hood and they
do red robin at this point oh yeah Drake
is a popular Robin yeah so I don't think
the audience is any problems knowing
your red hood is at this point I mean
between all the appearances of lady
Arkham Knights the comics he's got solo
lines yeah and they've kind of gone away
from he's a film that pops up once in a
while to he's full-blown bat-family that
a bat family doesn't even understand
nothing call him up so either hey Tracy
in town in town right after another
great hood marsena was really funny well
yeah it wasn't really funny line too so
it's so going that was that oh yeah
brother and the outlaws ended oh that's
right but ya know I think every comic
book fan probably is familiar with the
Red Hood in some way shape or form so
that's not like you've got them already
an audience's he was a Robin he died he
came back or didn't die they Batman
thought he died you're gonna because
you're not gonna be able to have a
resurrection right like you can't do it
that way unless they introduce like the
Lazarus pits in this Batman for a stupid
movie which everything else is in it so
why not but like they could easily just
be like he almost died Batman forgot
about like you could literally have him
be like Jason Todd died in the desert
and Batman assumed he died aw flashback
sequence at the beginning of experiment
does the origin exactly just see like
Batman in US and its plucky sidekick and
then the he and he thinks he dies some
people find him they catch him up but
he's mad and that's a movie and like you
could easily do that no problem I think
I audiences have no problem swallowing
it I hate the Red Hood I love the red
hood but he's my favor by the way I like
that book jug Winx book like I thought
that was awesome I was a cool under the
red oh yeah it's cool all right right on
but we can move on now like that could
be it elseworlds book I don't care but I
am you really just I done well and also
just to go on the whole thing of what
people really recognize you see like
Marvel's taking a lot of like be
Lister's you know who they are on their
putting iron man was see Lister now is
an a yeah DC's going I'm going long DC's
taking all their d-listers yes like
they're taking people you that literally
have no history so that they can rewrite
entirely yeah it's almost like DC
doesn't want to fight with comic book
fans like so they don't want to bring
you Dick Grayson because everyone's like
jig person wouldn't have done that you
know like well read hoods only been
around for like five years ish we can do
that yeah we can do it every why we got
firestorm in the shows we got white
canary yellow terrific mr. terrific
they're pulling all these guys that have
no history so that they can literally be
like oh it's a superhero we got but you
know nothing about him so how are you
gonna argue exactly exactly who's gonna
complain I don't plus like with Jason
Todd you could I mean you could do his
character literally in the opening
credits let teams of him fighting as
Jason Todd that's what it was turned
into in the comics he yeah member that
time I was Robin at this point I think
it was for a month but remember what I
think they could go so far with the
movie they could just say Jason Todd was
the only Rob yeah they no they don't
because we have the tombstone that some
reason okay oh that's right they got the
decree yet we have a totally stone
so he's the Robin to die yeah yeah or
they were they can actually I mean like
did you measure because you imagine the
revamping the whole thing they could and
it is great race and turns into red hood
I could see that no question that would
also be deals that would be DC's way of
being like cuz DC hates Dick Grayson for
whatever reason to rid of him oh no they
hate but they hate him with the fans
won't let him get rid but no who should
play did great or did know who should
like red hood then a guy that can wear
the hood way he has me around like like
28 so I don't know any actress Kate I
don't know I'm old now it would have to
be enough to be somebody kind of young
but somebody that looks rough you know
because someone that looks like a rug
it's too bad that he's either well but
Stevens even though perfect no but i
would take robbie amell I wouldn't take
steezy hmm maybe that's why Robbie Amell
dropped off the show and we got like
this really weird alternate the
firestorm am I the only one who's upset
that they were placed the they replaced
robbie amell on the show and put another
goofy kid like where's Jason rush
where's the actual other half of
firestorm he's already been introduced
in the show I don't know yeah so yeah I
don't know so we won't know we said it
Stephen Amell okay yeah he didn't say he
didn't say that it can't be possible you
suggested find Robbie Amell is outraged
on Steve Amell come on I would I mean if
they're willing to spend the money on it
like i would say i don't know they could
do it now because of a dark knight rises
but i'll just indeed Oh Joseph
gordon-levitt Justin Bieber I don't have
a reason for Justin Bieber DC would do
that to make you hate red hood there he
is he'd be like yeah we cast Justin
remember when that rumor was going
around he was robbing yeah he's red hook
is the only do they were like yeah and
like Batman's sidekick died yeah of
course she did well exact Efron VA was
right like he's the guy he's the guy
he's the name that came to my head too
because i have no cultural touchstones
boy he was actually good in that movie
where
it was like he was the frap the
neighbors yeah or whatever bad neighbors
out of her yeah does anyone have another
question let's hear it yes what's your
favorite movie if you don't know Battle
of the Gods for me and freezes still
like the peak of villains yeah yeah no
9s Bojack oh yeah yeah yeah yeahs
villains villains and movies all about I
know about all the gods is newer but I
like cuz all the other movies are pretty
much because everyone know well not
everyone but DBZ runs shows one timeline
movies are another timeline and the
comics are another timeline so the
problem I've always on with the movies
is they're always like one step behind
the shows so if you're watching the show
is like wow everyone's so not powerful
anymore Battle of the Gods is the first
time or you're like they're powerful
like we're gonna see some people beat
each other up ya know moving on was
really cool because Bojack knocked out
super saiyan future trunks in one hit
he's like ran a Bonneville was just like
wow and then he was he was out and that
was like that's that's why I'd like that
but Bojack was a really cool villain too
because he was so conceited you know he
was like a version of Aegina from
another planet you know so it was a good
thoughts on agents of shield season 3
and super I love them both of them yeah
super bra Libra whatever danger shield
is it they've gone away from being a
show and more to being like a movie that
is three seasons long yeah I will say
this though the whole lash twist yes
it's cool no no don't spoil it know what
I still haven't seen it oh I got spoiled
for me you know it so if I haven't seen
it I guarantee you other people haven't
seen the dress yet there is a twist and
it involves like okay we're coming to
the end of our time slot here guys so
does anyone else have any more questions
we'll we'll hang around chat with you
guys what we photos we want yeah like
yeah cuz we're not we don't have a booth
or anything like that anybody who came
in late Rhode Island comic-con pretty
much contact us like two weeks ago yeah
and they were to look hey guesstimated
for a panel like six seven months ago
you want to go still if you're not a
with who we are were three comical
youtubers we we do come on cameras we
basically that's comments explained he
is the chill version of the comic world
oh yeah no he left he Mila he heard
steven miller picket he's like oh no no
I'm so sorry and I do all the crazy
dramatic stuff this is Sal he hates
everything talks about it except for
comic we r comma club you I think you
really do hate everything is very few
that I've ever seen you feel like this
is a good book guys we're gonna talk
about it on back if she literally just
did a back issues yeah you don't watch
the show the literally the newest
episode Ivan wash it in a wild west
episode was here's a book i just love
whenever shrink i told them long ago
everyone thought let me I'm really mad
if it's like Benny do you like
everything and I'm like no I just don't
talk about stomach a while if you hated
something would you go to your friends
be like I hate this let's talk about it
I do that all that's called 1999-2000
five where I just talked about star
horse well yes no I commies displaying
comics Torian comic pop and our Twitter
handles which is what most people talk
to us i'm pretty sure a few people i
don't if you're in here have been
hitting me up being like i'm in rhode
island where are you you know we are
here's one of them so it's comic story
comments explaining Sal says what I
don't that go that's right but that is
who we are we also run a weekly podcast
the weekly poll which is what this is
when they asked us to show up we were
like we'll just do an episode live
because we have prepared nothing else
well that's that's the thing that people
want to see yeah I don't you know give
this is basically it but on twitch we do
it on twitch.tv backslash LOL stern
reuploaded comes to explain it doesn't
want itunes and soundcloud but if
following us on those two the guy who
uploads it for us it's always like three
weeks late and then you'll get like nine
of them at once like oh yeah it's got a
cool that's right that's yeah okay no i
have not figured it out alright no goods
in the bathroom yeah cool cuz he's
trapped in that suit oh yeah so how does
he like you know cuz he just goes in a
little wash okay is anybody seen at that
kid's movie back up back and like I
think it was like late nineties maybe
early two thousand but a kid who got
into a power suit and he couldn't get
out and they're like here okay so the
kid gets stuck in a power suit he's like
I have to use the bathroom but it's
built for an alien so like the little
like the bathroom dispenser comes out
his mouth and I think this isn't gonna
work
I'll do like okay so like like every
once in a while like let you read
through a comic and like you read
something like you like it's like a
panel or two and you're just like oh my
god that's so messed up and it just
sticks with you I was reading I was
wanting to do punish reverses the Marvel
Universe oh what a dark the dude was so
dark like I was reading through it and
it was win like the whole plaguing
everything broke out and Tony Sarg was
fighting and it's Iron Man armor seized
up and he was stuck in his iron man oh
yeah my partition was like this is like
he was he was talking in a flashback and
he was like they say he was screaming
for five days before he finally stopped
yeah and I was like oh my god that's
Garth Ennis by the way yeah hit me like
here's what I think of marble I want to
read that under shivers the Marvel
Universe he just screamed for five days
in suit because that happened in access
to but dead full show doesn't drag him
to a power source like he's in his armor
and then like he stops it like his arms
like it looks like a clean sound like
that and like he can't get out yeah he's
stuck he does the same thing to dr. do
me like he puts a magnet on the the
circuitry for dr. doom suit and then he
just beats the suit oh oh that's the
last amor para standing like murder he's
no Punisher kills the Marley Oh
furniture first oh you're talking about
the zombie book yes zombie boy that was
a good book to you know it's cool it's
also in continuity with all the other
ones like the Avengers vs. the Marvel
Universe wolverine vs the Marvel
Universe I read them all wow this is
dark entitled o it was different that
was very different but it soon oh yeah
nanos oh ok I think because there is
another panel coming in your guys we do
need to you technically closed it out so
but if you want i don't know how you
poking their heads in your ass that's
kind of like I'm just joking baited you
know they want to see if anyone's still
in here boy horoscope so on thank you
guys so much for coming but know what I
like what I want any questions guys want
yeah absolutely leaving we just got here